thank goodness we had those wins
yesterday nate we sure did
mid to low 50s right now in
mid 50s in boulder city and we've got a
lot of 50s around the las vegas valley
winds have calmed down significantly
there is a big change in the pollen
report so if you've been sneezing this
week chances are you've already started
sniffing out some of what's blooming
right now olive is showing up in high
counts olive trees one of the biggest
offenders we have in spring really gets
people's allergies going ragweed is
already showing up as well as well as
high counts of grasses overall we have
good to moderate air quality tomorrow we
expect a lot of dust back in the air as
we're going to get strong southwest
winds returning to southern nevada we've
got 50s and some low 60s but mostly 50s
around the valley this morning 46 out at
red rock a chilly 38 up there at kyle
canyon this morning so rough winds
coming back for saturday but here's your
easter sunday if you are going to
sunrise service temperatures will be in
the 50s early sunday morning mid morning
63 noon into the mid to upper 70s
warming up pretty quickly with sunny
skies highs in the mid 80s mid to late
afternoon on easter sunday for if you're
doing a late easter dinner the low
pressure system in california is moving
very slowly we'll get a few clouds from
it tonight but mostly we'll get the wind
on saturday wind advisories issued for
all of southern nevada and their
surrounding areas those are 8 a.m to 8
p.m we're looking at winds 40 to 45
miles an hour for your saturday that
could interfere with your outdoor plans
for sure 80 degrees today just a few
degrees warmer than yesterday lake mead
is going to be very windy and rough
tomorrow and dangerous so please if
you're going out there please wear the
life jackets it is free entry to lake
mead with the beginning of national
parks week tomorrow but please be
careful 80 for tomorrow mid 80s for
easter sunday and again lighter winds
we'll hop into low 90s that's going to
be a hot monday john but much cooler
next week at the end of the week on
friday with gusty winds and partly
cloudy skies we'll get back to some 70s